joining me now is newt gingrich fox news
contributor and former speaker of the
house new we'll get your thoughts on
ukraine in moments but first let's go
back to biden's kamala problem her
potential 2024 rivals must be loving
this
can you hear me oh look i died yeah i
could i i wasn't sure that i'm not
you're going to show some of how kamal
is unbelievable uh
the look i think we have never seen
a national political figure not just a
vice president but a national political
figure who is as
self-destructive
as kamala harris i mean you watch her
day after day you watch her go to poland
break up laughing in a press conference
with the polish president when she's
asked about
the refugees from ukraine you see her
10th person leave her staff who was by
the way the national security adviser
who was with her in poland who must have
been
totally embarrassed and demoralized by
watching her break up laughing when
talking about
the ukrainian refugees and you watch
other things she's done
and i you know i i thought that she was
an insurance policy to make sure that
nobody tried to replace biden no matter
how bad his cognitive problems but i'm
beginning to think that she's like
spiral agnew who turned out to be so bad
that when he got replaced it set the
stage for nixon to be replaced and i
have a hunch that uh that she's on a
very very short fuse right now
because i think most americans realize
that the prospect of her being president
is genuinely terrifying i mean it's bad
enough to think about biden being
president when he's clearly not totally
in touch with reality right but the idea
of being replaced by kamala i think is
astonishingly frightening
let me ask you this
if she's a vice president what could
this president forget that he's bite
what would any president with a vice
president like that do is there another
person that they would pull up in front
of the nation to at least deliver on
some of the issues americans want to
hear about what do you do in this
situation
well i mean the first thing you do is
you you send her to the
naval observatory which is the home she
lives vice president yeah and you say
please don't please don't leave for the
next three years and you offer her books
and movies and video games uh but you
don't let her leave uh the second thing
i think you do is you find somebody
whether it's the secretary of state or
somebody else
who you empower to go around the world
and pretend they're you but you don't
you don't allow her
ever again
to leave the united states i mean
it is people need to realize this isn't
just politics it's not just funny
you have people all around the world
watching the united states be
humiliatingly incompetent right and i
think it is a dramatic wound to our
position in the world
terrorists go anywhere you know i want
to get your your your sense of what you
think president biden will accomplish
when he goes to europe this week
well look i think the first thing you
ought to do
is make sure that there are anti-ship
missiles that are being sent to ukraine
right now i've not heard anybody talk
about this but the fact is when you
watch the black sea fleet of the russian
navy start to bombard the ukrainian
coast we have lots of missiles which are
capable of destroying those warships and
they ought to all be in the hands of
ukrainians and ukrainians ought to be
basically destroying the russian uh six
fleet six uh the black sea fleet right
which we could do we have that capacity
second i want to know whether or not the
high altitude anti-aircraft missiles
which biden promised last week are now
in ukraine
uh third by not to say if if
putin is going to engage in a policy of
killing civilians then we're going to
give
surface to surface missiles and cruise
missiles to ukraine so they can hit
russian airfields and russian missile
debases that are firing into civilians
we don't have to accept some deal where
the russians get to fight while russia
remains safe but the ukrainians are only
allowed to be on defense i think when
somebody starts killing your women your
children destroying your cultural
heritage
you have a right to defend yourself by
taking out their airfields and their
missiles finally
he ought to go to nato
and the number one thing they need to
agree on is a public
explicit commitment
that if
putin goes to chemical weapons they will
immediately within a couple of hours
do everything they can to destroy that
capability there should be no confusion
about none of this oh eventually
there'll be sanctions eventually we'll
do something they should go ahead
immediately all right new thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else